مشاهدينا انا الان في مركز بورسودان
لامراض وجراحه الكلى من المعروف ان القطاع
الصحي من القطاعات التي تاثرت بشكل كبير
جراء الحرب بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
سنقف على ما يجري داخل هذا المركز على
اعتبار انه يحتوي على 30 ماكينه غسيل
لمرضى الكلى ان كان هنالك واحد من المرضى
من الخرطوم
بغسل في مركز فضيل والمركز بقى
ومشينا على مركز في ابو ادم
والمركز برضه وقف قمت اتحركت على اساس من
بنات المنطقه اصلا
كم غسله في الاسبوع انا عندي غسلتين في
الاسبوع اربعه ساعات اربعه ساعات ولان
الامر عندي لا يرتبط بالمهنه فقط بقدر
ارتباطه بواقع انساني قد يتفاقم سريعا في
هذا المجال طلبنا من السلطات القائمه
التدخل وكانت الاستجابه سريعا بعد نصف
ساعه ودار هذا الحوار
تخص الولايه هنا يعني زي مشكله المويه
المركز مع الضغط الكبير بتاع العيانين
اضطرينا نفتح ورديات اضافيه بالتالي عندنا
اشكاليه في النوايا فمنحتاج منك انه توفر
لنا عليه الاقل تنكرين في الاسبوع بوادي
20 طن ده يمكن الطلب
بالاضافه لانه بالتعاون مع وزاره الصحه
تساعدونه في غير غير المستهلكات الاساسيه
بتاعت الغسيل الحاجات المعينه للغسله
المويه المحتاج لا نحن
التزام يعني ابتداهم في الكل اسبوع مرتين
ملتزمين بها في كميه من الوافدين
للولايه وبالتالي الضغط على على المركز
كان كبير جدا جدا نحن ان شاء الله حنجيب
معاك في المزرعه دي وكله معيناتة أنت
تقريبا ان شاء الله مع الجهاز
هذه الولايه تعاني اشكالات كبيره جدا
تتعلق
بالمياه وبالتالي هذا يضع ضغط كبير جدا
على القطاع الصحي وبالتحديد على مراكز
غسيل الكلى هنا في هذه المدينه بورسودان
التي من المتوقع ان تستقبل اعداد كبيره
جدا من المرضى القادمين من الخرطوم محمد
عثمان لقناته العربيه والحدث من مدينه
بورسودان بولايه البحر الاحمر شرقي
السودان
قاعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات